Вітаю!
Сьогодні ми знаходимось
на уроці з геометрії
за темою “Властивість
бісектриси трикутника”.
Перш ніж розпочати
вивчати новий матеріал,
давайте обговоримо деякі
опорні факти та поняття.
А саме, пригадаємо, що
таке бісектриса трикутника.
Бісектрисою трикутника
називають такий відрізок,
що виходить з одного із кутів трикутника
та розбиває його на два рівні кути.
Наступне запитання і поняття, яке потрібно
згадати, це поняття подібних трикутників.
Подібними називають трикутники,
відповідні кути яких рівні,
а відповідні сторони пропорційні,
тобто їх довжини відносяться однаково.
Ще одне поняття, а саме — перша
ознака подібності трикутників.
Сьогодні вона нам знадобиться.
І перша ознака подібності
трикутників звучить так:
два трикутники є подібними,
якщо в них рівні два відповідні кути.
Тобто якщо у нас є трикутник АBC
і трикутник A1B1C1,
то кути А і A1 мають бути рівними
і кути B і B1 мають бути рівними.
Тоді ми можемо впевнено говорити
про те, що два таких трикутники — подібні.
Наступне — Теорема Піфагора, мабуть
одна з найвідоміших теорем геометрії.
А звучить вона так:
у прямокутному трикутнику
квадрат гіпотенузи
дорівнює сумі квадратів катетів.
Якщо така рівність виконуються,
можемо говорити про те,
що трикутник є прямокутним.
Наступне — вертикальні
кути та їхня властивість.
Вертикальними називають кути, які
утворюються при перетині двох прямих.
І добре відома всім
властивість цих кутів,
це те, що вертикальні
кути рівні. Продовжимо.
Нарешті настав час вивчати нове.
Отже, перша властивість на сьогодні
— властивість бісектриси трикутника.
увага на дошку
Відповідно, нехай задано трикутник ABC
і відрізок BD, який є його бісектрисою.
Тоді довжина сторони AB
відноситься до довжини сторони BC
так само, як довжина відрізка
AD до довжини відрізка DC.
Давайте спробуємо довести цей факт.
Отже, розглянемо трикутник
ABC і його бісектрису BD.
Побудуємо перпендикуляри,
опущенні з вершин A і C на пряму BD.
Відповідно, на нашому зображенні
— це перпендикуляри AX та CY.
Розглянемо трикутники AXD та CYD.
Бачимо, що обидва ці
трикутники прямокутні.
Адже AX та CY — це
перпендикуляри, опущені на пряму BD.
Крім того, в цих трикутниках
рівні кути CDY та XDA.
Чому вони рівні?
Бо ці кути є вертикальними.
Вони утворені при
перетині прямих AC і BD.
Таким чином, ми можемо
впевнено стверджувати,
що трикутники ADX і CDY є подібними
за першою ознакою подібності.
Далі розглянемо трикутники ABX і CBY.
Ці два трикутники також є
прямокутними знову з тієї ж самої причини:
AX перпендикуляр до прямої BD і
CY перпендикуляр до прямої BD.
А це значить, що кути
AXB та CYB — обидва прямі.
Більш того, оскільки BD
бісектриса трикутника АBC,
то ми можемо говорити про те,
що кут ABX дорівнює куту CBY.
Таким чином, в двох трикутників,
які наразі підсвічено
помаранчевим та червоним,
є два пари рівних кутів.
Отже, трикутник ABX
подібний до трикутника CBY.
Давайте запишемо це на дошці.
Оскільки ми казали про
подібність трикутників AXD
і трикутника CYD,
то звідси можемо стверджувати,
що гіпотенуза першого трикутника,
а це відрізок AD, відноситься
до гіпотенузи другого трикутника,
відрізка CD, так само, як
відносяться відповідні катети.
Тобто як відрізок AХ
відноситься до відрізка CY.
З подібності другої пари
трикутників будемо мати наступне.
Трикутник ABX подібний до трикутника CBY.
І звідси випливає, що
AX відноситься до CY,
так само, як і гіпотенузи
цих трикутників,
тобто як AB відноситься до BC.
Звернемо увагу на те, що
в обох отриманих рівностях
у нас присутній дріб AX поділити на CY.
Якщо цей дріб однаковий в обох рівностях,
тоді однакові й інші
частини цих рівностей.
Отже, AD відноситься до CD
таким самим чином,
як AB до BC.
Що і треба було довести.
Адже відрізки AD і CD — це відрізки,
на які бісектриса BD
поділила сторону AC трикутника ABC, а
AB і BC — це дві прилеглі до них сторони.
Властивість доведено.
Тепер розглянемо задачу, яку можна
розв’язати, використовуючи цю властивість.
увага на дошку
Перш ніж розв’язувати задачу,
давайте спробуємо зобразити умову.
Отже, нехай нам задано трикутник
ABC, який є рівнобедреним.
Тобто AB=BC.
Далі за умовою, бісектриса
трикутника ділить бічну сторону.
З цього робимо висновок, що ця
бісектриса проведена із кута при основі.
Проведемо її із кута А.
AD-бісектриса.
За умовою задачі, ця бісектриса
поділила сторону BC на відрізки 2 і 4 см
починаючи від основи.
Отже, CD=2см, BD=4см.
Знайти основу.
Нам, насправді, достатньо
властивості бісектриси
та розуміння того, що таке
рівнобедрений трикутник.
Отже, оскільки AD бісектриса,
то за властивістю бісектриси,
BD відноситься до CD,
так само, дивимось BD до
CD, як прилеглі до них сторони.
Тобто як AB відноситься до AC.
Що ми будемо мати звідси?
Нам потрібно знайти основу.
А отже, з цієї пропорції
потрібно виразити знаменник AC.
Скориставшись властивістю пропорції,
можемо записати, що
AС буде дорівнювати АВ
помножити на CD і поділити на BD.
Але за умовою задачі нам не
сказано чому дорівнює відрізок АВ.
Проте ми знаємо, що
трикутник ABC — рівнобедрений,
а значить AB=BC і в цій формулі
ми можемо записати замість AB — BC.
В свою чергу, BC
складається з двох частин:
BD та DC, а отже, загалом
довжина BC буде становити 6 см.
Обчислюємо: (6*2)/4=12:4=3.
Таким чином, відповідь до даної
задачі — основа трикутника = 3см.
На цьому задача розв’язана.
Наступне про довжину
бісектриси трикутника.
увага на дошку
Подивимось на цю
властивість на зображенні.
Задано трикутник АВС і
відрізок CD є його бісектрисою.
Бісектрису позначили літерою l,
відповідно — навпроти вершин А та В
зобразили сторони а та b. Все як завжди.
Частинки BD та AD позначили як m та n.
Відповідно формула стає
простою – добуток сторін,
які утворюють кут, з
якого проведена бісектриса
мінус добуток частин, на які
бісектриса поділила третю сторону.
Це і буде квадрат
довжини цієї бісектриси.
Розглянемо задачу, яку можна розв’язати
з використанням цієї властивості.
увага на дошку
Почнемо із зображення трикутника.
Отже, нехай нам дано
прямокутний трикутник ABC,
в якому проведено бісектрису
із прямого кута C
на гіпотенузу.
За умовою задачі також відомо,
що ця бісектриса поділила гіпотенузу
на відрізки довжинами 15 см і 20 см.
Знайти довжину CD.
Розв’яжемо цю задачу.
Для початку скористаємося
властивістю бісектриси.
Бачимо — бісектриса поділила гіпотенузу
на дві частинки довжинами 15 см та 20 см.
А отже, їх відношення буде дорівнювати
відношенню катетів нашого
трикутника. Запишемо цей факт.
Оскільки CD бісектриса,
то АС відноситься до ВС так само,
як AD відноситься до BD.
Підставимо числові значення.
AD відноситься до BD як 15 до 20.
Скоротивши цей дріб на 5,
отримаємо відношення 3 до 4.
Введемо коефіцієнт пропорційності.
Тоді, оскільки АС
відноситься до ВС як 3 до 4,
запишемо, що АС = 3х, а ВС= 4х.
Для того, щоб знайти значення х
скористаємося теоремою Піфагора.
Як відомо, в прямокутному трикутнику
сума квадратів катетів
— це квадрат гіпотенузи.
А отже, за теоремою Піфагора
будемо мати — квадрат
катета AC, тобто 3х у квадраті
додати квадрат катета
BC, тобто 4х у квадраті
буде дорівнювати квадрату гіпотенузи AB.
Наша гіпотенуза має довжину
35, в чому не важко переконатись.
Все, що залишилось —
Обчислити значення х.
Давайте це зробимо, 3х до
квадрату підносимо почленно.
Знаємо, що окремо
підносимо до квадрату 3,
і ми отримаємо 9, і окремо
підноситься до квадрату x.
Загалом 9х квадрат.
Додати 16х квадрат.
Якщо ми порахуємо цю суму,
ми отримаємо 25х квадрат
і залишилось обчислити,
чому ж дорівнює 35 у квадраті.
Можете перевірити — ця
величина становитиме 1225.
Продовжуємо. Для того, щоб
обчислити значення х квадрат,
нам потрібно 1225 поділити на 25.
І, якщо це акуратно обчислити,
отримаємо результат 49.
Звідси х=7.
І тоді, знаючи, що АС =3х,
підставимо це значення у добуток,
отримаємо 3*7=21.
Відповідно катет ВС
становить 4х= 4*7=28.
Тепер маємо трикутник, у
якому нам відомі сторони
і відомі частини, на які
розбиває бісектриса одну з них.
Не важко, використовуючи
властивість довжини бісектриси,
записати формулу.
увага на дошку.
Підставимо числові значення.
Обчислимо необхідні нам добутки.
Все, що залишилось — обчислити
корінь квадратний із цієї величини.
Якщо уважно подивитися
на це число, можна помітити,
що його можна записати
у вигляді добутку 2*144.
В свою чергу 144 — це квадрат числа 12,
а тому 12 можна
винести з-під знака кореня
і отримаємо відповідь: 12 корінь із 2.
Задача розв’язана.
Розв’яжемо ще одну задачу.
Давайте поглянемо на наш малюнок.
Отже, дано трикутник АВС,
в якому АВ=ВС.
Бісектриса AD ділить висоту BH
у якомусь відношенні.
Для того, щоб його написати,
потрібно позначити точку перетину.
Нехай це буде точка І.
Тоді, за умовою задачі,
ІН відноситься до ВІ,
як 5 до 12.
Знайти відношення CD до BD.
Що нам потрібно для того, щоб
написати потрібне відношення?
Почнемо, власне, з нього.
CD відноситься до BD
за властивістю бісектриси
AD нашого трикутника
так само, як АС відноситься до АВ.
Але ж що таке АС?
AC складається з двох частин (АН+НС),
які є рівними між собою.
Ми про це знаємо, оскільки
трикутник АВС рівнобедрений
і ВН висота, проведена до основи,
а, отже, вона одночасно є його медіаною.
Таким чином, AC можна подати, як 2*AH.
Але ж з іншого боку, відношення AН до AB
можна обчислити із трикутника ABH,
використовуючи властивості бісектриси AI.
Що тоді будемо мати?
Це відношення нам уже
відоме і воно становить 5/12.
Виконуючи скорочення, отримаємо 5/6.
Отже, відповідь до
нашої задачі становить 5/6.
На цьому задачі на сьогодні завершені.
Але давайте пригадаємо вивчене.
За властивістю бісектриси,
сторона трикутника ділиться нею
у тому самому відношенні,
що і відношення прилеглих
до частин поділу сторін трикутника.
Для того, щоб знайти довжину бісектриси,
спочатку потрібно записати її властивість:
l квадрат=ab-mn.
Де a і b — згадані сторони, а m і n —
Частинки, на які поділена третя сторона.
Після цього для того, щоб
знайти довжину бісектриси
з отриманого значення, потрібно
добути арифметичний квадратний корінь.
Тепер перейдемо до
невеличкого підсумкового тесту.
Можна побачити, що обидві
ці сторони кратні числу 7,
і якщо ми запишемо відношення 21:35,
його можна скоротити на
7 і отримати значення 3:5.
Отже, правильна відповідь — Г).
Друге запитання.
Правильна відповідь буде варіант Б).
Оскільки відношення
1:4 говорить нам про те,
що й менша сторона з двох інших
відноситься до більшої, як 1:4.
Але ж за умовою, менша сторона=8,
отже більша — 8*4=32м.
Третє запитання.
Трошки поміркувавши,
маємо, що середній кут лежить
навпроти середньої сторони трикутника.
А отже, нас цікавить
бісектриса, яка виходить
між сторонами 4 і 6 і ділить
сторону довжини 5 на якісь частини.
На які саме, легко дізнатись.
4 відноситься до 6, як 2 до 3.
А оскільки всього довжина
нашої сторони становить 5,
то частинки будуть дорівнювати 2 і 3.
Таким чином, квадрат
бісектриси буде рівний.
4*6-2*3=24-6=18.
Пролунав дзвоник.
Нам пора на перерву,
бажаю усім натхнення
при розв’язуванні задач
і невичерпної енергії!